so i have an eye telephone i have an i
telephone
thank you
which means i have google on my phone
i'm guessing a lot of you do i have
google on my phone now it's ruining our
lives
i don't know if you've noticed it's
ruining life because we know
everything
but we're not a lick smarter for it we
just know
you don't know something wait
two seconds
you will
know having google on your phone is like
having a drunk know-it-all in your
pocket
there's no time for mystery or wonder
you're just like
how do they make glass
and you know
but the time between not knowing and
knowing is so brief that knowing feels
exactly like not knowing
so life is meaningless
i've literally been in bed in the
morning alone just like
where's tom petty from
[Laughter]
but i feel nothing because there was no
time to not
know
listen to me there was a time and i
don't mean to get all andy rooney on ya
but there was a time that if you didn't
know where tom petty was from you just
didn't know
and you felt that yearning and that
deficit in your being and you'd go
around and ask actual people
like where's tom petty from i don't know
i don't know i don't know and now i'm
impregnated with wonder and then they go
and ask people
until one fateful day you see a girl
wearing a heartbreakers t-shirt you rush
up to her and you're like hey where's
tom petty from and she tells you florida
and a wave of endorphins and pleasure
and meaning would wash over you and you
felt something and that's how you met
your wife do you understand
your wedding song was refugee
did biz laugh thank you very much
everybody good night thank you
that's great that was hilarious thank
you so much hilarious pete holmes
everybody
thank you that was our show want to
thank all my guests sarah silverman biz
stone we got andy richter jimmy dean on
the base of cable band stay tuned for a
little press tonight with his guest mike
tyson we'll see you tomorrow bye
[Applause]